how do flow artists get paid for the
work that they do i'm here with my
friend liz knights to have a little
discussion about that and hopefully get
some inspiration for you all out there
as well drex here from drexfactor poi
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow arts to benefit your
body and brain and today we are talking
about how you can benefit your body your
brain and your wallet before we dive in
i just want to give a quick shout out to
the friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyroterra light
toys spin balls and ultra poi for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that i've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel johnny howard les muchinski and
becca beckham thank you all so very much
for your support from my work and my
mission
liz hello how are you doing good how are
you i'm doing very well uh liz knights
is a dear friend of mine we've known
each other for over a decade and we are
at wesleyan university for uh spring
fire arts and we decided to sit down and
have a conversation about economics and
the flow arts because there have been a
lot of
i feel like posts recently about flow
artists not getting paid for the work
that they do so we wanted to have a chat
about how they can get paid for what
they do
so maybe to start things off liz um tell
the awesome people at home um how you
make a living with the flow arts and how
you got there
sure yeah so um my two main sources of
income right now are performing um so i
do a bunch of different flow arts i do
fire spinning and i do led performance
i also have branched out and i do things
like stilt walking i do juggling
so i do a wide variety of different
skills and then i'm also a booking agent
so
um that means that i am also finding
performance opportunities for other
performers and making money off of that
as well to see how i got there i guess
that's like part of what this whole
conversation is but i started i
started
um with it all as a hobby as i think
most people
do um
they're not just raking in the cash
right away and um
and
it just kind of like
slowly organically i started to get more
and more performance opportunities um
and i
was really into
making choreography
from the get-go
and i think that kind of
ended up leading to a lot of the
performance opportunities because i was
already making all these acts
and then people started booking them i'm
curious can you point to something that
was different about you that like a lot
of other people that came up at the same
time didn't have going for them that
like made it possible for you to turn
this into a full-time living where other
people just stayed as hobbyists there's
definitely things i think about the
qualities about me and then there's also
just um other things that i think
um just all sort of happen to fall into
place at the right time so i can't like
entirely take credit for myself like i
think it matters a lot
where you take a village yeah exactly
like it matters a lot where you are
geographically if you don't live in a
great place that doesn't for
um
doing this kind of work that doesn't
mean that you can't pursue it like you
can definitely travel and and find other
opportunities but that helped a lot and
like having a lot of friends who
um were already doing it as a career and
so like were an example for me um in
terms of
uh
personal qualities honestly like i'm
really good at writing an email
i think that's like
um
being really organized and on top of
things
matters a lot
in this field
someone told me at one point you know
just be easy to work with and i would
try to apply that to things as much as
possible and you also want to stand up
for yourself in the industry too but
like
um
yeah being easy to work with and just
responding to things on time and stuff
like that and i think like
seeing the places that i needed to
improve and
um and add on to my skill set i very
deliberately was like i'm gonna start
training hoops um because i saw that you
know
people could do that just as like
without fire without led and
um
and your average layperson wanted to see
that as much as i would love to just
like spin point every single
gig that i do and like just do that um
i knew that that wasn't necessarily
um
gonna yeah going to lead to a full-time
performance career well so there's a
couple things i want to pull out of
there that i think are really
interesting one of which being that like
you identified where the market was
going and that is where you directed
your energies to that like
it wasn't a matter of why will nobody
hire me it was a this is what gets
people hired this is what i'm going to
invest my time in you know understanding
that you're like offering a service to
people and if you're not offering a
service that they want
it's not going to go well for you yeah
100 like you have to look yeah you have
to look at what people
um want and what they're willing to pay
money for like you can definitely guide
that you can definitely like
teach people why they want to spend
money on what you do but also to a
certain extent you can't like
you know force people to like
spend money on something that they don't
necessarily want so i i'm also kind of
curious about things on the
administrative side because it's not
just that you do gigs but you book gigs
for other people
which um as a business person myself of
course like there's a little flag that
goes up for me there because that is
something that you know you can you can
do that at home that doesn't require you
to leave your desk that's so nice yeah
totally it is a way that you can earn
money off of not even physically having
to be at a gig that's just another way
of like diversifying income you know
like i mentioned like okay i'm i can't
just spend poi like i i need to branch
out into these other things um and i
think a lot of circus performers um do
end up
doing something in addition to
performing and that makes it all viable
and so you'll see like a lot of circus
performers also teach as a performer you
kind of have to almost wake up and do
interviews every day it's like you can
kind of imagine if like every time you
wanted to work you had to
do another interview which is a lot um
because you just have to keep kind of
selling yourself but yeah taking
taking all those skills that i was
already doing just to like get myself
work and then
apply it to getting other people work um
just made sense
well and that makes a great segue to
asking about um how do you decide whom
you're going to hire um yeah that's uh
just nepotism
so
yeah i mean
a skill level um
definitely looking for looking at um at
people's skill level and
um
their professionalism so like
do i know that they're gonna show up on
time and look good um word of mouth
matters a lot too like yeah um because
you just trust the people that you work
with and you trust them to give
good references um so that so that
matters a lot too
like
it also matters like is the person fun
to be around if i'm like working with
them if somebody were starting off with
a performance career right now and they
came and said give me one piece of
advice what would it be
oh my god just one
i mean you can make it a top ten list if
you want we've only got so much time i
know yeah i mean but i usually tell
people like
get some good costuming and
get some promo of that um
you know
that that goes a long way
so part of why i wanted to have this
conversation is that you and i both get
paid as flow artists but we do it in
radically different ways super different
super different ways and here's the
thing
both of them are the right way there's a
lot of different ways that they're the
right way
um so
i'm kind of curious what is it about my
business that
that you you were curious about and like
would want to know about what kind of
motivates you and drives you like on a
daily basis
great question um
so
partially anxiety but um
there was a point at which i almost quit
and what brought me back in was i got a
message from somebody who lives in iran
who was watching my videos and wanted to
share with me some of the stuff that
they had been learning and i like had a
no moment and um
realized that what i was doing could
have a real impact
like if so much farther and wider than i
would ever
be able to directly touch myself like i
have no shortage of ideas i have no
shortage of things that i want to say
it's always a question for me about what
is the thing other people are going to
be most interested in hearing right yeah
that's where i usually get stuck and
that's where
that that's where i usually require some
help at this point could you imagine
yourself in any other
i think that i've picked up skills that
would serve me well in a more
traditional job
um i i mean at this point i know a lot
about marketing and editing and video
production and
even just at a basic level
administrative stuff you know like um
there's no way that you can run a
business without knowing your way
through spreadsheets
yeah on a practical level no i love what
i do and i want to keep on doing it
um
but like
physically could i do that yeah yeah i
could i
i can see a number of marketable skills
that i have at this point that i could
apply to a traditional job if i wanted
to
i'm not interested in doing it though
one thing i have thought about a fair
amount is like if i wasn't performing
would i um
still want to do the booking work and i
don't i think the answer is no i don't
think i like that part of it enough um
to be like
doing it separate um part of what i
don't love about that is um i don't like
like feeling like i'm wasting my time
and so when i put a lot of energy into
trying to like get a gig or something
and um and then it
goes to someone else it's like it's not
that i am upset that they got it but i
don't i don't like feeling like i've
wasted my time sure um
and i will say that that is one thing
that i really appreciate about being a
content creator is like scarcity if it
exists at all doesn't work in the same
way you know there there's no such thing
as a scarcity of people's attention yeah
um they're you know as long as i keep
producing content there are people that
are going to keep on watching it and
likewise
you know
the limit on the number of people
watching flow arts based content
is not a limit on the number of people
out there the amount of attention they
have it's a limit on the amount of
content there is for them to consume and
we are
so far away from saturating that at this
point somebody goes from i enjoy this
thing too i'm going to get paid doing
this thing or i
i am going to make a living doing this
thing which those are three very very
different phases
what did each of those three phases look
like for you and how did you know when
you had gotten to the point where you
were ready to move on to the next phase
uh step step two profit
step three four five six like i think
it's just important to
not skip the step of um
do i enjoy doing this thing that i can
make money off of right like um
you know you there there are a lot of
different ways to make money in the flow
arts um and i think
we've talked about this like i think
that it can be easy to just like look at
someone who's having fun you know being
a performer or whatever and
not necessarily like take
you know stop to think about like
whether you actually really enjoy
performing you just sort of like see
this model and you're like okay
i guess that's the next step i have to
take it doesn't have to make you happy
like a lot of work doesn't make people
happy but like you know if that's if
that's your goal you know that you're
ready to start
earning money off of it like
if you
you know if you want to do it and if
people are willing to pay you i guess um
you can try out like a
couple of performance opportunities i
think um
i think just
trying out um performing in non-paid
settings um can kind of like give you a
feel for it
i did a lot of
performances at various flow festivals
and so that was definitely like a good
place for me to sort of test the waters
on it and you don't have to be
like
the most high skilled performer to to
start
and in terms of like
having it be your living i feel like
that's kind of a financial thing like um
you know
uh
figuring out whether it's something that
can actually like sustain you or not um
you know you and i came down on opposite
ends of this equation because i i hate
performing with a deep fiery passion
and i very specifically arranged my
income stream so that i would never have
to do it again whereas you know i
you're an amazing performer and you're
one of the most successful performers i
know
and at the same time i i know that as a
content creator that is something that
you know you enjoy doing but from what
i've been able to
tell from talking to you that is
something that you're neither passionate
about nor do you feel like the
investment of time always equals out
like you know what what what you're
getting back out of it you know yeah and
that's something like i've made a very
deliberate decision about in terms of
the content creation is like
because
i
make money off of flow arts and these
other other ways like i kind of want to
keep
the content creation just like for me
but yeah like i just want to have that
part not be work
and just be something that i can
yeah i can do whatever i want yeah for
sure i think one of those central
questions
buried within this is that question of
what am i worth
um
so how did you come to a point where you
decided what you were worth and how did
that impact business for you you sort of
get to a point where you're just like
we're just like
this is the amount of money that i want
to make when i do x y or z you know like
you you start you'll be doing something
and you'll just feel like
huh that just like wasn't really enough
like for all the work that i put into or
whatever and it took me a while to
understand like all the things that i
needed to be
charging for
um and a lot of performers when they
start out they
aren't considering like
charging for all the work that goes on
behind the scenes the quote you know the
booking work so like
the time you spend making a contract and
and and all that stuff um you know at a
certain point if you're doing it as your
um
full-time career
you have to think about the same things
that everyone has to think about so you
have to be like is this covering my rent
is this covering my
roth ira you know how much money do i
need to be making given my lifestyle and
what i
you know yeah what i'm spending money on
too well cool thank you liz i really
appreciate you joining me um i hope that
there was stuff for y'all out there that
you enjoyed learning from this it has
been a pleasure and where can people go
to follow you on social media um you can
find me at
liz knights on instagram
and you can also find me on facebook
where i am elizabeth knights um for
whatever reason i don't know why
i'm also on youtube but i don't post
there um very much so yeah but feel free
to reach out to me with questions i'm
i'm always happy to answer questions
about this stuff
within reason
cool
well if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe to keep the
conversation going and of course to help
my channel grow this video would not be
possible were it not for the kind
support of all of these nice people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible
if you enjoy these videos and you want
to support me in my mission you can do
so by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and you'll be helping me out in
my mission thank you in advance if you
want to check out a bunch of other
videos that i have done on flow arts and
flow arts business i will leave a link
to a playlist down in the description or
up on screen if you are watching on
youtube thanks so much for watching uh
get out there and break some eggs
yourself and hopefully
i will get to interview you someday on
what kind of business you run yeah take
care have a good one and enjoy the flow
i'll talk to you soon
peace bye
should we like do something like click
bait thing where we're like we discuss
why tick tock's bad no
just kidding